[Music]
we see your family meet Peter they love
people yeah your cousin calls him winter
yes winner leaving that day how did you
feel I thought Peter had the first
hometown date and it went really well
Peter's Peter my family felt the same
way that I did about him and you know
you see him reveal himself to me in a
way that he hasn't before which is
something that I had been waiting for
and so for me it was very refreshing we
see you in Peter in tears and he says
what is wrong with me what is wrong with
Peter I think that's something you have
to watch and find out like Peter said
something was wrong with him like he was
had been there that long because I saw
what was right now and we kind of hit a
crossroads and I think that's something
you'll see play out in the episode and
what's to come you guys also come to a
real head on this engagement issue
that's not what that means to me though
and I struggle with that then for me it
was if you are the one I want an
engagement from the person I feel that I
that is the one for me and if you don't
want to engage then I probably will walk
away because I didn't come this far for
a boyfriend or a commitment I could have
done that without a show let me ask you
Dean told us that brian has raised some
red flags for him and that he's worried
you're blinded by lust what is your
reaction to that
those are Dean's opinions whatever like
I can't speak towards them but I I would
hope that people and the viewers know
that I am smart enough to not be blinded
by lust
I'm 32 this is my first rodeo I've been
in love before and every decision that I
made was heartfelt it was logical and it
was well thought out it was a real
decision that I took my time the best I
could in nine weeks we have found some
some footage of back of a Brian on an
old reality show called the player went
viral what's your reaction to that I
mean I think that that was like a show
that aired when 2004
like 13 years ago I mean 13 years ago I
was the what night
8cm I came into the math like I mean
like whatever it is I didn't know him 13
years ago I know him now and heaven
forbid stuff comes out about me 13 I
know so like I don't know Brian 2004 I
know him
2017 so he's not a player anymore from
what I understand for my show
[Music]